what do you think it takes to build a
system with human level intelligence you
talked about the AI system in the movie
her being way out of reach our current
reach this might be outdated as well but
this is still way out of reach what
would it take to build her do you think
so I can tell you the first two
obstacles that we have to clear but I
don't know how many obstacles they are
after this so the image I usually use is
that there is a bunch of mountains that
we have to climb and we can see the
first one but we don't know if there are
50 mountains behind it or not and this
might be a good sort of metaphor for why
AI research was in the past I've been
overly optimistic about the result of
way I you know for example a New Orleans
Simon Wright wrote the general problem
solver and they call it the general
problems you have problems okay and of
course the 15 you realize is that all
the problems you want to solve is
financial and so you can actually use it
for anything useful but you know yes oh
yeah all you see is the first peak so in
general what are the first couple of
peaks for her so the first peak which is
precisely what I'm working on is self
supervisor running high how do we get
machines to run models of the world by
observation kind of like babies and like
young animals
so I we've been working with you know
coming to scientists so this Amanda
depuis who is a at fair and in Paris is
half-time is also a researcher and
French University and he he has his
chart that shows that which how many
months of life baby humans kind of
learned different concepts and you can
met you can measure this various ways so
things like distinguishing animate
objects from animate inanimate object
you can you can tell the difference at
age two three months whether an object
is going to stay stable is gonna fall
you know about four months you can tell
you know things like this and then
things like gravity the fact that
objects are not supposed to float in the
air but as opposed to fall you run this
around the age of eight or nine months
if you look at a lot of you know eight
month old babies you give them a bunch
of toys on the highchair first thing
they do is it's why I'm on the ground
let you look at them it's because you
know they're learning about actively
learning about gravity gravity yeah okay
so they're not trying to know you but
they you know they need to do the
experiment right yeah so you know how do
we get machines to learn like babies
mostly by observation with a little bit
of interaction and learning those those
those models of the world because I
think that's really a crucial piece of
an intelligent autonomous system so if
you think about the architecture of an
intelligent autonomous system it needs
to have a predictive model of the world
so something that says here is a wall
that time T here is a stable world at
time T plus one if I take this action
and it's not a single answer it can be
education yeah yeah well but we don't
know how to represent distributions in
high dimension continuous basis so it's
got to be something we care that data
hey yeah but with some summer
presentation with certainty if you have
that then you can do what optimal
control theory is called model
predictive control which means that you
can run your model with the hypothesis
for a sequence of action and then see
the result now what you need the other
thing you need is some sort of objective
that you want to optimize am i reaching
the goal of grabbing the subject about
minimizing energy am I
whatever right so there is some sort of
objectives that you have to minimize and
so in your head if you had this model
you can figure out the sequence of
action that will optimize your objective
that objective is something that
ultimately is rooted in your basal
ganglia at least in the human brain
that's that's what is available Gambia
computes your level of contentment or
miss contentment oh no noise that's a
word unhappiness okay yeah this
contentment this contentment and so your
entire behavior is driven towards kind
of minimizing that objective which is
maximizing your contentment computed by
your your basal ganglia and what you
have is an objective function which is
basically a predictor of what your basal
ganglia is going to tell you so you're
not going to put your hand on fire
because you know it's gonna you know
it's gonna burn and you're gonna get
hurt and you're predicting this because
of your model of the world and your your
predictor of this objective right so you
if you have those you have those three
components you have four components you
have the the hard-wired contentment
objective computer if you want
calculator and then you have the three
components one is the objective
predictor which basically predicts your
level of contact and one is the model of
the world and there's a third module I
didn't mention which is a module that
will figure out the best course of
action to optimize an objective given
your model okay yeah cool it's a policy
policy network or something like that
right now you need those three
components to act autonomously
intelligently and you can be stupid in
three different ways you can be stupid
because your model of the world is wrong
you can be stupid because your objective
is not aligned with what you actually
want to achieve okay and in humans that
would be a psychopath right and then the
the third thing you the third way you
can be stupid is that you have the right
model you have the right objective but
you're unable to figure out a course of
action to optimize your objective given
your model
you